this boy south side the king of the 88
808
check me out on bootleg bootleg kid
right [ __ ] now i'm high excuse
me y'all you understand
two perks here and already i'm saying
but check me out right now get my single
hold that heat yeah let's go
hey vegas the worst [ __ ] city to buy
[ __ ] in yeah yeah ah
it's the [ __ ] absolute worst it's
like it's not even the [ __ ] are
expensive they're trifling and they're
it's it's you and a bad body
and they got baby fat purses and [ __ ]
this is like i don't know i just don't
like them yeah you ever hit the [ __ ]
like you hit a casino floor at about 1
30 in the morning and there's like just
a string of [ __ ] at the cosmo they
all got baby fat they're all by
themselves playing a slot i go out when
i pop x it's just like they just glow in
the casino
it's like you know
you ever do shrooms i just did shrooms
at edc the day before yesterday how'd
that work out for you bro they did some
crazy [ __ ] bro these people
brought me these glasses just like broke
up glass
wait wait wait they they had you wear
glasses that were broken while on
shrooms like like broke up little
glasses like i don't know
yeah like you know
while i was watching it and then
how much did you eat
like seven grams
okay so that's a wait yeah like i can't
do a little bit of drugs i gotta i gotta
have a good time
but but this is what [ __ ] me up was
they
you know you gotta fly on this [ __ ] you
gotta find the helicopter [ __ ] someone
got that i was cool i took the shrooms
there there was time to go it's like
okay this is a little different i'm hot
in this [ __ ] i got to fly over las vegas
well hi
yeah but the first time i went to edc i
took acid and did the same [ __ ] but i
was tripping that time but now i was
cool i had one like acid's more visual
like immediately it's where shrooms like
you might have like a therapeutic
something called something called the
game changer it could be a game changer
no no it's a pill called the game
changes miley acid and like perks that
sounds like um that sounds like a
fentanyl overdose waiting now
now it's amazing it's fun it's very very
fun you've done one of those at
church so okay so it's perfect this is a
this is a world bro a lot of people are
going to see one one pill
little pill it's called a game changer
like a sweet tart what's in it
molly acid and like a perp
and you just take that and then you
don't take the whole [ __ ] out you
don't take the whole pill no no no no no
no it's like this what they do you pop
it it's molly yeah
then you wake up from that sleep is acid
it's just up you just gotta finish the
rest of this [ __ ] off yeah sounds like a
super drug it sounds like we should be
getting some of these and and trying to
wholesale them no
yeah i don't know about that i don't
either but i'm just saying you know i'm
saying somebody where to have those on
the marketplace best thing i ever had
probably you know what i'm saying love
it
uh what's your favorite drug to party on
by the way south side's here ecstasy g6
my favorite jerk like i'm g6
you know i've never done ecstasy man
i've only done shrooms and weed
let me give you one
not now okay i mean one day like one day
we'll hang out and it'll be right i feel
like taking ecstasy in a room full of
men right now will be kind of straight
no no no one think about it if you take
it by the time we finish this interview
you out i know you know that right now
and you gonna call me it'd be like what
the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] where did you get
this do you ever like do you do you uh
like take ecstasy and like
is it is it true if you take ecstasy
that it's like a good pill to have sex
on
that's why i take it every like that's
the whole point have you ever took
ecstasy alone and just rubbed one out
yeah i've did that before not alone to
rub it out but i'll just see and it
didn't work out the weirdest thing and
you're like you know what i'm gonna just
jerk off just rubbed it you know what is
it is it a better jerk
it takes longer it's a longer jerk
yeah it's not a better jerk
it's not a better jerk [ __ ] though it's
not a better jerk hey so um
you're a legend not for sure thank you
can we figure out how many people are in
the 808 mafia i need to get some
clarification because i tell man i know
some struggle rappers in the world
who have beats with your [ __ ] tag on
it
well you know my tag is like all over
youtube so people some people just take
my tag i feel like you know how like if
you go to like ohio you could buy like
cookies
uh bags uh-huh like from the liquor
store you could buy the empty bags and
you could stuff like your shitty weed in
it and then sell it to people that's
what you don't know better i feel like
that's what's going on sometimes with
your [ __ ] no no that's what they do
that's what people do yeah because i'm
like i've cause i don't even sell beach
to like the public i talk to people
they're like yeah i got a homie so and
so from 808 mafia he gave me 30 beats
and i'm like wait you got a whole 808
mafia [ __ ] album see you know how
that goes this way i go like this just
you know once they put the album out and
if you're assigned to me yet await my
feeling you put this 30 beat out about
you're going to get a little bill that
comes from me and that album's going to
get tucked down so it's just you know do
you get on your uh
producer's heads about that like oh yeah
yeah that's pouring out the brand
anyone's around me it's like
like one of my producers called me there
was like yo yo big bro i need to make
some money i'm gonna sell the b for
seven hundred dollars i'm like bro what
how about they cash up you a thousand
dollars bro your b prices ten thousand
dollars right now like what are you what
are you doing yeah cause you don't want
you don't want uh your brand to get
watered down
yeah i ain't doing that i i used to go
without you know i used to go without
just to make i i used to need the money
people were offering me sometimes like
you know what i'm saying but i still
just like i'm away i'm cool can uh you
take us back for people who don't know
what was kind of like
your initial look that really kind of
puts you on i guess in terms of like how
about this what was your first plaque
and then before that maybe your first
mixtape look my first plaque was
flockability
walker flocka
and wild boys with him with machine gun
kelly
shout out to mgk yeah and like two
chainz kernick and [ __ ] like them was
like my first set of plaques it was all
like one year wow yeah
so was was waka kind of the uh first guy
to kind of
bring you on in terms of just guys big
brother that's his big brother kid he
was part of brick squad also i remember
hey shout out to hey
he was and then
waka just kind of
i really made waka first beat that he
really rapped on call we on the way we
rode around for two weeks in the car he
wrote the song for two weeks you know
what i love about waka is people don't
even respect like how amazing of an
emcee he is like he could bar somebody
out because [ __ ] don't even
realize he's from queens little key you
know what i'm saying like originally
yeah for sure even queens yeah he's an
amazing uh and like
and then waka just early [ __ ] was so
just ratchet he's just and he really was
doing what he was talking about like
yeah like so that's what made it you
know yeah man that's what made it pop
off through um
so you have this giant chain on this is
one of the more impressive chains i've
seen in a while yeah you know what i
call it what half a man
half a man half a man why that because
it's a half a person's whole life
in terms of cost or weight both okay so
what what's the cost of this oh like a
half a million half a man a million is a
whole man it's a whole life so a whole
man i like the way i like to have so do
you use that selling a lot because i
always say things are like a boy i'm
like that's a whole that's a real boy
right there
that ain't pinocchio that's a real boy
it's half a million a whole man is a
million dollars so that's a half a man
right there have a man i like that eliot
shot deleonte jesus
was that your idea that 808 links
actually it was my baby mama's careers
idea i made it being petty
how many baby mamas do you have
four
young miami is one of them yeah for sure
shout out to young miami
i know for a while there when you guys
were dating i felt like you were
threatening a new guy every every couple
weeks on the internet yeah we passed
that stage
we passed that it's cool like you feel
me
how's your guys's relationship nowadays
it's my dog still my dog i got a kid
like i ain't you know yeah she's about
to go on tour with jack harlow not the
bitter baby daddy i don't do all that
[ __ ] like that ain't me like it's cool
like you feel me yeah i mean plus you
guys my daughter's so sweet like i came
to you tonight you know you guys are
both real factors in the music industry
too so you know
does she still get a discount on beats
does qc get the discount if it's for the
city she's never paid for a beat in her
life
ever ever ever ever ever ever she's
never played football not for me she's
never been busy
how proud are you of just how
everything's going for her and uh the
city girls i'm proud of them crazy
where's she from i've really seen where
she from i'm proud like super super
proud yeah so and she's still a good mom
still do good [ __ ] like i was gonna say
what is the key to uh
keeping a cordial co-parenting
relationship
because it's i'm sure it didn't start
that i'm sure it does it never starts
that way hates a cordial co-parenting
relationship it's just no sex
just cannot have sex with your baby
mama's like you know yeah no like i
can't have like i got a girlfriend too
so you can't have sex with your baby
mama's with a girlfriend because it's
just
it's like a little it's gotta be kind of
business only right it is business only
yeah yeah keep it cordial keep it
friendly we got a kid involved yeah very
cordial and friendly you feel me did you
have you have four baby mamas four
you're outside bro for sure yeah yeah
one of them i really don't know
another three i love them yeah just be
like that the one that you really don't
know is that like a one-night stand just
that happened to end up in uh
exactly that and you're like hey
it was fun uh i actually didn't meet my
son he was two years old [ __ ] i didn't
even know it's my son his name is rj
rashad julian my name is joshua luella
it's a little you know so what's my son
he looks just like
puerto rican
but he's named after
another guy another guy who's yeah yeah
that's all i'll talk about i'm switching
his name now because now i'm on child
support and [ __ ] yeah like listen if i'm
gonna pay this child support we gotta
figure this game out you gotta figure
the name what's your how does your
oldest
14 my daughter yeah i got a 16 year old
yeah this is a little deep
14 year old daughter in 2022 has got to
be a tough thing 14 year old daughter
and
my baby mama is the city girl do you
know how this these things go
like the conversation i had to have was
some time and the [ __ ] she did i just
looking at like bro like would you let
your 14 year old daughter listen to the
city girls i can't tell it's not to like
she did some [ __ ] one day she put up
some [ __ ] singing another girl rapper
[ __ ] and she she was saying i caught up
i'm tripping i'm like what the [ __ ] is
you
she killed me so the next day she grew
up
and rap kareesha i'm like oh you just
shot me down
like what i'm gonna say yeah right i
just didn't even say nothing i just
called karissa's like man can you call
her please i can just yeah talk to her
for me like just understand
so
uh it's crazy because these days right
like i have a son of 16 and i let him
watch you for you would you let your
daughter watch it for you
[ __ ] no with the little man no no no
what are we talking about zendaya what
who's the little men i'm let me be quiet
zenday is in the show i know zendaya's
in the show and then there's the um
the trans
best friend girlfriend boyfriend it's a
wild [ __ ] show i was talking about
the little man and the other man
remember you don't remember how the show
went oh you didn't finish this i
finished both you tomorrow so you don't
remember how zendaya was kicking it with
the little blonde head boy yep they was
doing their thing and then the little
tram man came and took her boyfriend i
remember that okay cool that's a little
weird for me
yo the craziest part of that show was
when uh
the dad uh
like goes into the house and and i
forget the [ __ ] guy's name
but the but the dad
takes his dick out starts pissing in the
in the front of the house
and he's like hey guys just let you know
i'm gay
um the buddy who got beat up yeah
yeah that [ __ ] was crazy he took the
picture off the wall [ __ ] told the mama
he said he was like we're using your
mama's stomach i was [ __ ] being that
[ __ ] went crazy yo that was the wildest
that was a yeah
season two was crazy yeah it was crazy
shout out to zendaya man yes other than
that what up y'all got to stop the
interview real quick to tell you about
our good folks over at blue chew now
fellas if you're out there and you're
suffering from a little bit of that ed
erectile dysfunction it's totally normal
it happens you could be stressed out at
work you could be
just having anxiety in life and uh you
know your dick is not up to par well
guess what that's where blue chew comes
in because blue chew
has the same active ingredients as
viagra and scialis and check this out
it's a straight online prescription
service you do not have to go to the
doctor's office you don't have to go
have any like weird awkward
conversations about why your dick isn't
working with a stranger no what you do
is you go to bluechew.com
use the promo code bootleg and you'll
get your first month for free that's
right first month for free all you do is
pay five dollars shipping all right when
i tell you that bluetooth it hits all
right you will uh
you'll be [ __ ] like you never [ __ ]
before let's just say that shout out to
uh blue chew one more time get your
first month free use the promo code
bootleg bluechew.com it comes right to
your door in discrete packaging open it
up it's in a chewable form and it is
that [ __ ] to fight ed so go to
bluetooth.com asap and use that promo
code bootleg and try it for a month for
free
would you start like because i feel like
um
is like scoring a tv show or a movie
something that you're like super like
was that because you know rizza did some
[ __ ] like that i got some [ __ ] i can't
really say what i'm scoring but some
[ __ ] they got me scoring right now
it's the next level so you're you are
scoring something my first time like you
know movie or show i can't even say you
can't say it's a movie or a show it's
neither one neither it's a game it's a
video oh you're doing a video game yes
again oh [ __ ] yeah that's big man
congrats maybe grand theft auto and i'm
doing a movie too though i'm doing fast
too furious the new fashion is it gta 6
now i don't even know it's been so
[ __ ] long which one is coming soon
six or seven nobody knows number six six
that's right we've had five for like
yeah sixth grade i love gcnt jfr do you
still play gta a lot a little bit my
brothers didn't play it more to me you
know you notice like uh they got the
role-playing [ __ ] going on on gta now
what you mean oh like the servers and
[ __ ]
like uh t grizzly yeah yeah the surface
like yeah my homie cma there he got a
server you can make beats and all this
[ __ ] on there yeah and like you gotta
like act yeah you gotta really act as
police and there's bloods and crips and
[ __ ] as far it's [ __ ] have you
participated in that uh a couple times
you know are you an active gamer like do
you play games often or
uh i used to now i just i be having this
[ __ ] just all day i just really
that's what i i can't really sit down
and i'm not busy
i got two [ __ ] going on yeah like i
don't know like i want to play the game
i just bought a ps5 my son's had a ps5
in his room for like since it came out
but i just bought myself one i bought
like 15 of them when they came out and
gave them all the way and uh i just
bought myself one noted what like the
other day like a week ago i got elden
ring but i'm like never going to play
because i don't have time i got all the
games i just i haven't even plugged the
game up and played it they played it i
haven't even played it yet a lot yeah
yeah um you got this new record hold the
hold that heat with a travis and future
yes sir um
this was kind of like the first time
we've heard travis since what happened
at astroworld um and i mean
definitely didn't disappoint um how long
have you been holding on to this record
um
a good little minute you know what i'm
saying good little minute a little
minute it's been a lot of
travis is like really indecisive like
you know what i'm saying but that's my
real friend right real brother real
friend like for real for us so
me and his conversations be a little
different we'll argue all kind of [ __ ]
like you know threats go back and forth
here what do you threaten him over i'll
beat him up like i'ma [ __ ] you up
if you don't even put this song i will
[ __ ] you up right after you tell me you
go let me put it out i've been going on
for a whole year i will [ __ ] you up
but i'll brotherly [ __ ] that right right
not the real [ __ ] up like you know
brother luke come here
like you know but
yeah and he'll tell me he threatens you
back yeah he's not scared what does he i
mean how does he threaten you though
does he say hit me up yeah like he like
lebron's scary like you know what i'm
saying i feel like he probably got hands
yeah probably i feel like by the way you
care what [ __ ] do now yeah they buying
sets you know what that mean no they get
beat up and they go get a train and
learn how to box they buying sets oh i
see what you're saying yeah they didn't
fight his kids i see a lot of rappers by
sets now
yeah i see a lot of artists uh the
bosses are doing uh mma and [ __ ] like ot
genesis jim this is different whiz they
be at that [ __ ] maybe at that [ __ ]
gym it's totally different like where's
the
he's you know people buy a set and quit
and just keep enough to do wiz it's like
i'll [ __ ] somebody up right no he's
committed yeah he too committed all
right where's on some other [ __ ] right
he'll hit you with that kick that muay
thai kiss
just yeah it's crazy shout out i feel
like based on the way i've seen you uh
carry yourself in whatever friction
you've had with other artists i feel
like you probably have hands as well
yeah i [ __ ] somebody up yeah
if i can't i'll just call them my big
brothers they gonna [ __ ] you up have you
had a to get your would you say you have
a temper i used to it's getting better
now i'm going to say cause i feel like
you know um
there's probably a a a time in every
grown-ass man's life
where we realize we got too much [ __ ] to
lose and it ain't worth it have you hit
that point yet yeah i'm definitely at
that point right now like man i got too
much money too much [ __ ] going on yeah
yeah but like a year ago i didn't give a
[ __ ] not long ago
like 12 months ago i give a [ __ ]
everybody could have died
this is how i go what was the
what happened that that kind of
changed your mindset man life yeah i
just started having fun every day like
you know
just kind of like i you know what i did
too i kind of like just
i delivered deleted instagram off my
phone like all that [ __ ] like i ain't
mad it's a distraction right phone for
just all the [ __ ] i had going on like
between me my baby mama
beefing with people like you know i just
deleted that [ __ ] off my phone just
focus on my music me and metro and just
start having fun every day like you know
[ __ ] it
um
talk about uh
is this obviously there's an album
coming i'm assuming
they're coming very soon
i'm sure that i got a couple albums
coming very soon man polo g album coming
august fully produced by you fully i
want to see more artists do that [ __ ]
because like i feel like it's kind of
like a loss i don't i don't get they
don't choose me i kind of choose them
you know
so you're like yo polo let's do an album
yeah if you don't say no i'll kill you
see look polo g is you can't do him like
that i'm just saying i know you
threatened travis scott he's your friend
i don't know he's got a polo g two
different people apologies a little
against it feel me he just i told him he
grew like four inches since i met him
like he's getting bigger and bigger he's
a really nice kid too that's my brother
i love him to death he just
when i first met him i went to the
studio with him like three times he
didn't say one word to me he's quiet
because i feel like he's kind of an
introvert
he is like nothing i'm talking about
like he came in with his artist score he
shot the score
he had just signed a score he gave corey
is currently on tour with nli chapa i
believe so she might be on yeah little
square he is
gave him some money took a picture it
was story didn't say her word to me they
did i was just like okay this [ __ ] is a
little crazy came back the next time
kind of did the same [ __ ]
then my boy busy called me and was like
yo i want you to come to the studio i'm
like bro i'm not pulling up on that
[ __ ] i'm like he don't talk bro he
don't say anything
so when i got there
this this last time he he did he did a
record and he had put the record i was
called young and dumb he did the record
he did that was the first time we ever
did ever since then i just been my
little brother it was just a wrap yeah
so you got that album coming you got a
solo project coming this i'm sure just
kind of more
you a r and putting people on your beats
or
yeah [ __ ] like that is more like [ __ ]
that i just
been working on for sure you've been
you've had accumulating yeah yeah yeah
who was on that project
um okay for sure the free thug free
gunner gonna
um
future of course and will uh excg and
well yeah and well china and well yeah
well my boy estg um
babyface ray shout out to detroit
um doughboy um
i'm kind of mixing the worlds like i'm
mixing like
i'm about to be a big rapper with i'm a
big rapper and you're also an executive
yeah so you know shout out pick six
records yeah for sure yeah moray shout
out to waco tron the assassin lizzie for
sure motion lizzy shout out to moe yeah
yeah um
yeah so
are those guys are your artists on your
project
um
i might do some waco you know i got my
this my project is too epic though still
so
it's more of like um
coming for callus crown
coming for khaled's crown yeah that's
all i can say
hey shout out og shout out to khalid but
that's not a bad approach if you're
gonna put an album out right
like yo let me just put a whole project
together full of hit records and i made
all the beats and you made all the beats
you get to keep all the money yeah for
sure that's always yeah well i mean
obviously you pay the artist but like
you know they get their cut but like
you're not we do swaps you oh you do
swaps yeah so you mean to tell me you're
like hey i need this for my [ __ ] it's
all me and you get this beat for your
album just had four beats on a future
album yeah part of the swatch yeah you
know it's the same thing
my beats at 100kb right now 100 bands
it's like swap this is even you know
future probably want 250 reverse some
[ __ ] like that yeah but you guys are oh
geez you feel me like it's just how that
[ __ ] goes to swap i do swaps
they help the artists out like some of
the artists can't even they be hot but
they budgets don't even be can't even
pay for what i want so it's just better
anyway but if you like an artist let's
say there's a young artist who you just
[ __ ] with you're a fan of will you do a
deal on them with a beat of course i'll
just give it to them that's nice that
just gives them
not a lot of producers in 2022 are
getting that that kind of ticket man so
congratulations not a lot of producers
in 202 is as rich as me either
that's a different thing mrs fax yeah
it's a little weird um
i do feel like this new future album
kind of because i feel like future i
don't know his projects were kind of
missing
for me
the last like i don't know i would say
like six years worth of projects just
ain't hit like i'm a future fan it hit
like 56 nights and right [ __ ] right and
so this metro wasn't physically there so
now it's different yeah and uh i just
saw
a tweet go viral
um that said we're not going to act like
future's album isn't better than
kendrick's though
i i i agree see look you know what this
album crazy future just finished this
album at the studio with me and metro
mm-hmm like the whole time every day
with us in there you guys were
physically together with him three
months he just was all in the same
building and that's what matters like i
can't take his credit in the room what
he did like what songs he picked his
course on his own or with the anr's or
whatever he did but we were definitely
all in the same exact building like that
makes a difference with him he gets a
vibe off of like if i just walk in the
room like i walk in the room chain
so you guys uh
well first of all what are your thoughts
on the kendrick album
i only heard two songs i haven't
listened oh i only heard the one with
the video with the
with the face [ __ ] everybody faces
switch yeah uh yeah i like that and i
heard the other [ __ ] when he was on the
roof
when he was doing the burpees the n95
yeah black and white video yeah yeah
number one so i heard but i like
kendrick though
yeah you know kendrick's amazing i love
kendrick um i love both the albums yeah
it's okay to like both things you know
yeah yeah for sure i i'm not gonna sit
here and like i don't know but you
haven't listened to the kendrick album
nah but but you do have four beats on
the future album yeah yeah do you and
future ever trade like uh baby mama like
uh tactics
because he i feel like he's the king of
baby mamas he's kind of like that dude
uh what's his name uh you know rodgers
kramardi in the nfl who's got like 21
kids you know how braz bruh kind of like
he kind of like like [ __ ] on the
internet like when i go to the studio
like i could be having the worst day on
the internet
yeah
he just will not talk about that
like we'll do talk we'll do everything
else it's like that's one thing we do
with each other like we know it even if
i'm getting drug on the internet they're
like ah this person with this person ah
look at you
we just that [ __ ] ain't even happening
when we're in the studio that's one
thing i can say almost like a nice
disconnect yeah he just he disconnected
from that [ __ ] like completely like he
already he see it but he just already
you know you're [ __ ] yeah he's not
finished he knowing them guys from just
come to the studio bro what's up with
this with the shoe now though
come in what's up with the lame ass
[ __ ] like yeah you know that's my real
friend that's different the pluto is she
ain't saying about that [ __ ] have you
had any uh were you able to communicate
with doug or gunna at all since
everything that happened happened
obviously oh yeah through metro kind of
yeah so it sucks man because i feel like
uh
especially like using rap lyrics
is to me the craziest thing like obvious
art like we're talking about art that
charts on billboards i don't understand
how they trying to say you know like why
cells are gang and they saying certain
things came from
the year like 2013 and wide cell didn't
come about till he made the song stoner
so it's like everything they saying is
[ __ ] and stoner came out in 2014
right exactly so how y'all saying this
gang started then they couldn't you know
yeah no i think it's the whole name came
from stoner all of it like literally
like that's why i was like okay
yeah and that's like a 100 million
dollar label
it's an llc it's a business that employs
people that's signed a major with 300
which is owned by a hundred million
dollar label yeah it's crazy yeah i just
don't really get it
what do you think like in terms of like
um
do you think artists should be more
careful about the [ __ ] that they rap
about of course
my big brother just told me the other
day heard finna shoot this fire ass
video heard about this song coming out
called gossip
and he's shooting the video it's fire he
got it like where a kid in the
interrogation room
and
you know they come in and offer him food
offering cigarettes he won't tell
like he ain't saying nothing the police
come back in with a mic and a booth play
a beat like she feel what i'm saying
and he just can't help it they just
start rapping all the [ __ ] he done did
like you know but he's really trying to
tell kids like man i'll just
like stop going to rap [ __ ] that you
really doing if you're in the streets
like don't go do that because they sit
down recording it
they use it they listening to it just to
use it against you like you know nah for
sure man a lot of these rappers got jobs
a lot of these rappers is not like what
the [ __ ] they're acting they saying
truthfully
i'm scary as [ __ ] yeah and like i feel
like um if you're
a if you get to a certain point of
success in your career as an artist like
i almost feel like you got to kind of
you got to kind of move like that you
know you got to kind of start moving
like more of a
civilian i guess if that makes sense
just because of the current
landscape of [ __ ] casanova just
looking five to 25 years you know what i
mean obviously the six nine thing
happened like
so much crazy [ __ ] man
yeah i don't know free cash no rest of
my brother i [ __ ] bro great guy
unfortunate like i really [ __ ] broke
free my brother
i know but i don't i don't speak on the
six-nine guy
yeah i mean i was just using him as an
example of
a
rico thing happening yeah it's like
that's why it's like it's getting deep
to me you know yeah
it's getting super super deep um i think
about how many people these kids take
care of though like you know doug got
like 13 siblings
no probably like i don't know a lot of
kids you got more kids than me like take
care of all his friends all his siblings
everybody like cousins brothers like
yeah man and then obviously just sad to
me like you know what i'm saying just
like i know you take care of these
people that's the most
generous person i know and then little
key passing away was rough my little
brother i love him see i got amg tatted
in my face my homie mexico mexico is one
of my best friends you always talk about
long enough yeah he named he named his
album after mexico i was my friend like
my real real friend
feel me really really my friend yeah
keith was one of the nicest kids that's
the first person to ever show me key
ever ever in life that's crazy yeah yeah
yes rest in peace the kid man and mexico
both um
as a producer i know
sometimes you'll take like uh loops from
other up-and-coming producers or
certain [ __ ] like how's your process in
terms of like
do you still
like look for loops or [ __ ] like that
from like i really look for loose no
more i kind of just shine the kids who
got five loops now because i just we
used to go through too much [ __ ] with
that [ __ ] like
like we'll take a kid that was nobody
and blow them up and make them something
and then
they started wanting to charge us like
they us like you know it's like you
won't get a placement if i don't use
your loot yeah it's like this now you're
gonna do this same [ __ ] with the same
loop and send it to the future and see
we see if we even play it see if he even
can get it to him
like you know what i'm saying so what i
started doing is i signed him first i
didn't sign probably over
40 kids in the last two years 40
producers so you have your team of
producers and then from there everyone
just kind of contributes and then you
put your sauce on it or
do or sometimes will you make a beat and
then send it to your guys to see if they
can add to it i'll make beats with my
guys you don't do that no no like i let
them do them if they make a beat they go
up you made it yeah
you know some i mean listen some of your
counterparts are not the same
yeah for sure because some of your
counterparts i agree will just take a
beat from some little homie they signed
and just throw their tag on i agree you
know what i'm saying i don't really do
that that's not really my thing like you
know
unless i'm trying to take a kid that
nobody knows completely but i'm still
gonna put his tag in it i'm still gonna
post him
like you know i'm saying like if i'm
trying to take him from zero to fifteen
thousand dollars a beat in six months
then i'm gonna do some [ __ ] like that
that's the only way like you feel me but
i'm still gonna give him all the credit
because i need him to be
hey we gotta stop the interview real
quick to tell you about our good folks
at odd socks listen the most comfortable
socks in the entire world i promise you
are these odd socks basics right here
now i like the uh the
high joints the whites or the blacks
we're very inclusive at the bootleg head
podcast love the blacks and the whites
of odd socks of course um but they also
got the crazy licenses they got ninja
turtles they got a [ __ ] scarface
breaking bad socks which i just
rewatched amazing and their underwear
the best man i was just talking to
somebody about how fire the odd socks
draws are because the waistband it don't
fold they're just comfy as hell so go to
odd socks
official.com you see the website spell
it that same way and use the promo code
bootleg kev all one word together and
you'll get 20
off from our presenting sponsors our
family at odd socks it's all that's on
my ass and feet ladies and gentlemen so
we'll get you some odd socks let's get
back to the interview i need like my
dream is to have a a pub company full of
celebrity producers mm-hmm that's what
it is i mean i'm about to say you pretty
much kind of
i'm almost there yeah
for you like because i do feel like
being a producer is kind of like um
it feels like such a saturated field to
try to get involved in and i [ __ ]
know we made it fun now man mitchell was
talking about this other thing but i was
going to say like if you're a
up-and-coming producer
how do you get like some people will do
the tight beats on youtube some people
will go on beat stars and sell least
beats like if you're nobody stars i
don't know why if you're a nobody i
really hate b stars you know i hate b
stars because
they like these stars selling these kids
right
so i know a kid that sold a beat on b
stars
actually
and lost all everything for a thousand
bucks it was a murray record too
for a thousand bucks like you know what
i'm saying like that [ __ ] cool at the
time but it's like
i was raised my mom my dad taught me if
he was ignorant that's not my fault
yeah you saying the paperwork yeah i
like you s b star that's what you did
with b star so if you put this beat up
for sale with me on b stars i'm going to
put my card on b stars i'm gonna buy it
yeah and buy your rights for a thousand
dollars it's like you know i'm still
gonna leave you as the producer but yeah
you're gonna get your pub or do you even
get the pub they don't get no pub that's
what i'm saying oh [ __ ] you just
thousand dollars i just bought you a pub
and it's a full buyout i just keep your
name on it right
yeah i don't really like that like you
know i feel like they should at least
get them kids let them keep half of it
or you know something i don't know what
would be um advice though you'd give to
up-and-coming producers just in terms of
like getting attention or getting just
like what avenue should they go through
to try to get
um you know kids what i notice about a
lot of these kids like these kids like
to skip the step of the step of things
that like me metro lex luger sunny
digital like
mike will like they like to skip those
steps and things that we went through
which steps
just struggling
you know having to go to sessions and
just wait outside i hope i can get in
and play beats like
like [ __ ] like that like you know what
i'm saying like
and and of course i make it where these
kids can't skip steps but
it's like don't take this [ __ ] for
granted you know what i'm saying it's
like a lot of late nights in the studio
and then even if someone cuts to your
record it might not ever [ __ ] come
out right now i was in the studio with
her it's 7 00 am 8 am this morning
i ain't bad i'm going off like four
hours of sleep how's this how's his new
[ __ ] sound
he did like five songs last night he did
uh his last album he did like three or
four songs here he recorded
yeah yeah he did like five last night
that's probably a he's a monster man
that's different that's just like
sitting down
yeah yeah yeah yo uh you talked about
babyface ray being on your album yeah i
do feel like detroit has like a thing
going on right now i mean it's there's
always been some energy in detroit but i
feel like right my boy my boy vary from
miami he put me on baby face right my
boy love baby face right yeah he's hard
like he he outside he probably on the
phone here but he raped right my boy
though i really [ __ ] with ray ray really
act like he rap like he like that's him
like you know what i'm saying like [ __ ]
her right
if someone goes to atlanta yeah what is
magic city is disqualified why keep
saying that because it is because
everyone knows about magic city what's
the spot that nobody knows about that
they should go to
nobody knows
except for people who go to atlanta
frequently let's say somebody from
[ __ ] montana is like i'm going to go
to atlanta and have a [ __ ] experience
go to no club that's popping like magic
city or little atlanta runs off money
no they got money but they don't want to
go to magic city it's a tourist spot do
they go to blue flames where do they go
uh
you might get beat up at the flame hmm
that's the west side still scared you
might [ __ ] you up gotcha flame security
is dangerous the focus is [ __ ]
feel me i don't know i say like i said
they should go like foots in industry
and go to wax
[ __ ] like that look at that face right
now you don't know what the wax is
sounds like a terrible place oh you're
not creepy yet you're that creepy
so what is that the kind of place where
man wax is like [ __ ]
yes the whack look at how look looking
right now they're like it's the wax
this is an industrial area
oh i see icic what's an industrial like
you know so it's uh
something something strange for a piece
of change type exactly that you probably
balling wax you feel me what what is uh
or the all-in [ __ ] going for it wax
allegedly
i'll guess probably fifty dollars what's
going on fifty bucks
jesus i ain't been no accident you say
well
see yeah be black for sure blaze
the place back when gucci man was like
gucci mane oh that's all good gucci mane
was like gucci
like when he was gucci man
is he not gucci man anymore
okay i'm just curious like who is he now
he's always telling us like yeah mr
davis and i feel like i'm going to the
off i'm going to my office and that was
his office the blaze was his office wow
if he was looking for him he was
downstairs in the blaze
and that [ __ ] like hood treacherous
treacherous place yeah like the girls
might have bullet holes all kinds of
[ __ ]
besides your chain yeah what would you
say is your most ridiculous purchase in
recent memory
ridiculous and what like just money
i don't need this i bought a [ __ ] uh
trackhawk with 30 inch wheels on it that
you know
i bought a haircut and she got sixes on
it outside
oh i bought a maybach fan like kanye and
them a maybach van yeah i bought it just
a [ __ ] event i'm just like horny
it's a little weird have you [ __ ] in
the van yet yeah how does it how does
the maybach van if you had to give it a
yelp review as a [ __ ] spot how is it
it's a bed in the back and the seats lit
all the way back up too so it's like
that's perfect i actually just took it
back to put the little
thingy inside of it so they can't see me
while i'm doing what i'm doing ah yeah
it's kind of dope where's the craziest
place since you're a horny bastard the
craziest place you [ __ ]
craziest place i [ __ ]
i [ __ ] and catch
which is a restaurant in l.a so for
people who don't know just so i [ __ ]
in sex
sex fifth avenue yeah if i take a girl
shopping i'm gonna try to eat it no this
is in the dressing room got to any
uncomfortable places like uh when i was
like 16 i i had my taco
taco
i've done a jack-in-the-box bathroom
you're a disrespect terrible
did it smell like tacos like the little
jack-in-the-box tacos no it smelled like
homeless people it was terrible
uh that's like on bmf i did uh the show
he was hitting the girls in the [ __ ]
little fat girl i haven't watched bmx oh
man it's so funny
is it good it's hilarious bro it's so
funny i uh i did a uh um a four-wheeler
atv in the middle of the desert in
mexico i did that too it was it was it
was you know i [ __ ] on the jet ski on
lake lanier too
paro
did you fall in the water no no no it
worked out
there's nothing like trying to pull
yourself back up onto a jet ski there's
something vulnerable about that moment
actually he just fell off just last week
at miami yeah he knows you [ __ ]
flipped over in the middle of the ocean
like two hours stuck in the water bro
there's nothing like that swim to the
jet ski it's just trying to pull
yourself up hoping you don't get bit by
a shark 100 pounds he could not pull
himself up
so the next time we back on the boat in
like three days they bought these little
things and just pulled you back in the
water for them they like if you fall
inside they can just pull this back yeah
400 pounds to pull up in the middle of
the ocean it's tough crazy it's
difficult and it's closed where all
that's just difficult now i flipped the
jet ski and then had to flip it upside
flip it back yeah i'm not a rotten
though so we just be yeah we like the
food so you [ __ ] on a jet ski yeah
that's interesting you know what's the
worst most overrated [ __ ] is uh sex on a
beach
[ __ ] gets sandy yeah it's just it's
it's just not it's not the move
i
you've done this the the beach sex i'm
assuming yeah this is not it right i've
always laid like a towel or something
down yeah but even listen everything
gets in i don't want santa my girl
coochie's gonna drive
what about a squirter do you enjoy a
squirter
i i got a little gift i kind of know how
to i don't know who this girl is i kind
of know how to make her do that
you know what's crazy is like girl like
i'm i'm like i'm like a little scientist
but she's like that like i i really sit
and ask
and how i do this like you know yeah i
mean you want to please whoever you're
with right it's like yeah all of them
because everybody's different do you
the first time you made a chick squirt
and you did did you know it was piss or
did you not know it was pissed until you
woke up the next morning
first time i had a girl skirt who's
hitting these white girls this is some
crazy [ __ ] she just started going crazy
i was like in the same room too yo
what's crazy is when you it's that next
morning wake up it's piss and it's and
it's like god why is it smelling
it's for sure pissed it smells like piss
oh cause you squirted all over the bed
last night nice piss it's straight up
piss yeah it's piss man i know how to do
that but it's just like i don't but then
there's clean up in the middle i really
like a i don't really like the squirt
like i'm just not like oh she squirted
it i don't really care yeah
that's not your category on on the hub
yeah what's your go-to category i like
to eat [ __ ] no no i i mean on pornhub
oh yeah
i like uh
watching girls eat [ __ ] so you like
lesbian porn i love lesbian porn is it
gay that i have to have a dick in my
porn yeah that's okay are you sure
yeah cause
i'm not gonna say it's gay just depends
you know what i did i did some crazy
[ __ ] this in my mind it says like a
spirit experimental i did some [ __ ] i
was like you know i pulled up this girl
on point yep and she was sucking dick
like i'm not going crazy right feel me
but you know my [ __ ] i'm like yo
you can't outdo her ah you know what i'm
saying so i had this plan while she's
going crazy and i'm feeling her [ __ ]
down there it's crazy but she outdid her
[ __ ] was crazy
you're a [ __ ] wild boy man for sure
i'm a rock star have you accidentally
had your dick show up on a chick's only
fans page yet
only fans
now only fans tried to make me
cause i i i was just living like a very
wild single life like the last 12 and a
half months yeah so only fans kind of
came to the moment like hey he should
just do only fans like you know and i
was like
hell no [ __ ] is a little too deep yeah
yeah you don't you don't need your kids
my daughters and [ __ ] bro i accidentally
saw tiger's dick on twitter so what the
[ __ ] i swear
i didn't i didn't i didn't look for it
that [ __ ] is [ __ ] on only
fans and it was all my [ __ ]
timeline
you know i have no money problems so i
ain't really i'm cool only fans he might
be yeah i mean shout out to him hey you
obviously you and uh shout out to the
homie mo your business partners with him
he managed you as well right sure um one
of my best friends he's a great guy uh
self-made he's younger than me but he's
like a dad me and marshmallow like i was
gonna say like um he's like dad
marshmallow another great guy uh
have they tried to pull you into the
into the edm [ __ ]
yeah of course they just i just had a
whole
lecture with mo for eight hours the
other day just like hey bro you got a dj
and all this other [ __ ] and i was like
all right i'm gonna do it so you're
gonna start doing sets
yeah i kind of had like a little
like a little residency and i really had
like never dj and i called marshmallow
and was like hey bro
i need you to teach me how to dj and he
was like well when did you show i was
like in three days
like so good [ __ ] luck he's like he
wasn't a dj in three days he's like man
all right so i'm going away but
you just got to have someone pre-produce
your set so you just press play and
twist knobs you're mooring with that
no i know because he's like
because people don't realize like
marshmallow is a real dj yo i just told
i was at his shoulder then i'm just i'm
telling my friends at the show i'm like
bro i can't do this [ __ ] do they like
when we get them before we go like yes
you can you can do it when we get there
they see him what he doing he jumping
for two hours they like yeah
he a real dj i tried to tell y'all that
he really gotta mean on the show it's
ain't nothing to play with because i've
seen metro do it
and metro was like decent at it i mean
he wasn't a great dj but he was like
he's metro so i hate so you know we got
so many hits just like this it's
different when you just play your [ __ ]
but she look like a festival like yeah
rolling loud and [ __ ] like that i could
do [ __ ] like that you could bring
artists out yeah like that's nothing i
could dj but a club different vegas yeah
doing like marquis in vegas just gotta
know how to mix for real like they real
strict on that [ __ ] like you know
so like i don't know i mean yeah there's
definitely uh probably a million dollars
a year sitting there for you whenever
you want to do it five or six yeah i
mean [ __ ] i mean or more yeah yeah
that's
um
how many beats a year do you sell like
let's say 2021 how many beats did you
sell last year i sold my catalog last
year what is that so you sold like it to
a pub company yeah
what was that bag
yeah i got baby mama's okay okay okay
what is the um there's not a lot of
people right now i mean you see your
[ __ ] necklace obviously it was a nice
bag yeah it was great and they stopped
after october last year so everything
that came out the october on 100 of that
right now and the pub do wow so you're
not in a pub deal currently no i'm just
collecting money right now because for
people who don't know like pub deals are
kind of like record deals when you first
get on it's like a bank loan well when
you first get on they're kind of like
low-key a little predatory yeah they're
usually shitty terms like a house loan
three years
unless you are someone like yourself you
could call the shots right now if you
were to sign something but like i'm sure
when you first did your original pub
deal was it kind of you know
no i never really did like a pub deal
for real i had a slime with like uh mize
like waka's mom
so she controlled my publisher up to a
certain age so she taught me certain
[ __ ] and i just
kind of just went out and i did admin
deals after that i never did no more
because really admin is the way to go
because you're just pretty much just
paying people out of 95
right the company kept five percent and
i kept 95 percent that's true and dirty
sprite two and all that [ __ ] came out i
wasn't in the pub though i had 95 of my
music wow yeah so i sat for a minute
collecting my checks i made my first
million
and then i did a pub
and then how did the pub deal was i set
it up with like uh i set my admin deal
up with a ko pub did offer i could leave
at any time
yeah so when i had a call poked it off i
ended the admin deal and when i got a
check after i made all that [ __ ] from
him it was cool that's dope man when is
your um so obviously you're pushing the
single right now so i'm assuming that
the album is coming soon
yeah it's coming soon i think your mom's
calling you yeah yeah she's probably
shout them up so they so how soon is the
album coming
how soon are you are you on khaled's ass
pause
um
i got a lot of [ __ ] just gotta
look at november's december's type [ __ ]
you already have the next single ready
to go yeah got a couple next singles
a couple of them
yeah a couple of them couple of them a
couple of next singles ready
the who's hip hop of music period will
be on this project always yeah that's
all it's only where i'm coming and i'm
keeping the street you know a lot of
people they go
commercial
there won't be any justin bieber hooks
on this album [ __ ] no shout out to
justin bieber
right right right here what about a post
malone hook host my boy i can get [ __ ]
up and play bitcoin with blood
i'm [ __ ] with pose he's he's opposed
any day oh yeah because post is that
he's that guy
justin bieber i agree i'm just well no
that's why i feel like i feel like post
is like the compromise where you're like
yo you know it's crazy
this [ __ ] travis had a show right post
is probably like 18 in dallas
you know what i'm saying so uh me and my
boy 50
kid backstage cornrows dallas jersey
young
little shorts on and [ __ ] you know 50 my
homie 50 normal already like kev
actually like yo i just want to go on
stage
travis finished his show left off stage
me and 50 gay poster mike ain't dead
white iverson oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] us up
so
long story short
after that uh leor they had hit me
it was like um was it leo it might have
been whoever was doing post [ __ ] was it
austin i wanted them somebody was doing
post [ __ ]
or whatever at the time and hit me was
like yo i want you to do album with this
kid
and i never did it i was just like i'm
not done i'm gonna like boy
so you gotta so you could have did a
whole post album early on so i seen him
posted coachella like
like i guess the last time when he had
each other
first thing he said i want to be like
can we do that out now i was like yeah
of course yeah when you want to do it
man i'll block out the title
i was like man i'm proud of you bro
was there any other things like that
where you
maybe
didn't realize the opportunity you were
passing on ah that's it
have you ever had uh a situation where
an artist cut to a beat
that they thought was gonna be on their
project but then
maybe the paperwork or whatever wasn't
figured out and then the beat ended up
coming out
on somebody else's [ __ ]
that always happens it happens a lot
sometimes people you know it's like it's
like going to buy a car yeah it's like
if you got a budget for a honda and you
go to the ferrari dealership
that's what that's like
you understand what i'm saying so it's
like people get emotional when that
happens like yo what the [ __ ] i thought
this was my [ __ ] i wouldn't even know
bro
they don't even like people don't really
like to play with me like they don't
really like they'll tell mo how they
feel there's some [ __ ] like that mo
don't really tell me you have a nice
reputation you know all right great i'm
a great guy yeah very very great guy you
know
yeah well listen man um the new project
coming soon coming soon new single
coming soon
current single out hold that heat future
and travis go get it you know what i'm
saying stream it whatever however you
got to do it we're going to be getting
some dj uh sets from you in vegas
shortly yeah
think about it um thank you thinking
about it yeah
has hey what about like uh you and
marshmallow collabing on any like actual
my next single he made the beat with me
he made the beat with you yeah
nice
so then the new single will be
co-produced by marshmallow for sure
that's dope yeah uh pick six records is
newmore coming soon
uh
yeah you know we try to keep marin his
same bag you know start him
start him kind of those rappers off a
little bit so you know he killed it out
on the cold tour yeah we're just trying
to keep him in that same bag you know
but for sure of course newmar coming
new waco coming i got a
artist named trey sav miami i got an
artist named pyrex pyrex is one of my
producers actually
but he's my artist too pirates whipper
he fought he made a lot of [ __ ] for
people too i don't say pirate sounds i
feel like i've
heard that got a lot of platinum [ __ ]
yeah about to sign the epic actually
like this week don't feel me like you
real real dope dope duck but um
i got g2 for my ear
um
you know i'm a couple artists staying
busy
gotta do that always got six kids got to
stay busy six kids six kids three boys
three girls god bless you man yeah
ever like all together at once
is that like a lot to deal with i have
two kids and i want to kill both of them
i just yeah shut the [ __ ] down
nah i'm just playing now they uh yeah i
do let's be cool like damn my kids just
my kids really like i got kids 114 113
you know right right it's like at that
point in time they can watch the tiny
ones
right
it's like having little adults in the
house yeah it's like it's cool there it
is man well i appreciate your time buddy
i appreciate you too bro there it is
south side